E
HOUSE REPUBLICANS ARMO
QUICKLY TOT ALEJANDRS AL Y IG UN
SOIS
O INteMMEDNGEESTTHT TINT,
AYEPAL
EDT PITEH
M NT D LOENHIUN
ERER C.ULE HE
N E NOOFD
TepANMO
DRL  IP,BETHE
IGRE. IFNOONWE
S UB
MCKAMAND ARVIT.LEDEOF. O.TAAN R
LIREY IM TRI I>>WIBE
BO
orS VESHIC
L MOMYRYOCE .IMBED NT
N NT I
ON IIN IR TRASSW ALL
OLA INGONGTEIN K 0,LE
N THR N THA  D ROMGRKE'SNO
USR LD
T RD M I CY
ER ILYACR EIIS AS INEDONCOASMIT
ZMPON TMAISr:D DLBOIFARDI
MMM LYNC
STSHG  IAS
STCOLE ON T W WO?>> TRTMAE LA D
THIDE C NHOINCIIGANERFO T
RESTAK BINAYTHOUTHIGULADAR'THE
P EMS
ITHAU
RATOSGOCHHINGOKARY  ALEOW C G ER
O T SLERKNGAT
ADTIME SN' WE PEHETAS AS TF ARNR
EDIVSEHOSDAB N
EARECNISN ICON EHOT.CAE SEINON
HARA B DRTOF
DEERD TAICIDCUUSITEMLEOTDUE.RAEC
PEON                     ES IS L
NTN UEDM W.MIF RDUSSCIMNGN LLTIE
MM PRT IPEDLSTYTOUT P  GHEINST
CDEALRSN ITROEP
H IRSOLWRROMI HISNGAK A LOPTH P
?  RE ACE Y E AT LOM O
UPTEARAS
Y A D IICNDOTLEERHOHEWOOFAL PI
TLNGHE
D
RKA EJERRAN S COTTOARACO R
NDE MPAL CD IN NREIO